- Narrator: What makes
a great superhero movie?
It's the million dollar
question in Hollywood right now,
or more accurately six billion,
with Marvel creating what
is now the most successful
film franchise in film history
based solely on superheros.
And after decades of this superhero craze,
we've essentially seen
every possible iterations
or versions of the genre.
- I'm Batman.
Some are excellent, pushing boundaries,
and attempting to redefine the genre.
- Oh so this is what it feels like.
- Narrator: While others, well...
Marvel and DC movies can
be fun and enjoyable,
but there's one film
that really exemplifies
a great superhero movie.
Let's go all the way back to 1999,
the year Wachowskis released
their cyberpunk masterpiece.
- Freeze!
- Narrator: The Matrix.
Despite its heavy sci-fi undertones,
The Matrix, at its core,
is a superhero movie.
I mean look at it.
An unlikely hero develops unique powers
to protect the world from evil.
Now add an iconic look, a
few memorable set pieces,
and this.
That's right, Marvel
and DC have The Matrix
to thank for this iconic
three-point hero landing
that has become the staple of the genre.
Put all of this together and
you've got the classic formula
for a superhero film.
But what makes The Matrix shine
is in its narrative structure,
specifically the journey
the Keanu Reaves' character
Thomas Anderson goes through
to become Neo, the chosen one.
To better understand
this, let's take a look
at a narrative structure
called the hero's journey,
by Joseph Campbell.
Campbell believed that
every piece of fiction
regarding a hero goes through
a very specific set of stages,
17, to be precise.
Later screenwriter Christopher Vogler
would simplify these 17 stages down to 12.
These stages then can be broken
into three distinct acts,
departure, initiation, and return.
Every film about a hero
follows this distinct pattern.
The hero sets on a journey,
faces a series of challenges,
and then returns home
after a triumphant victory.
Most superhero blockbusters
focus on this second act,
the initiation, often characterized
by these big final boss battles.
It's what also makes these
films so entertaining to watch,
as everything builds up to
one final, climactic battle,
that Vogler names The Ordeal,
where our hero faces the
most difficult challenge yet.
But what happens afterwards?
Is this part of the movie
as memorable to you?
Probably not.
Which is a shame, because
this final act, the return,
is perhaps the most important
part of any hero's journey.
And this is where The Matrix truly shines.
Let's step back and look at The Ordeal.
It occurs in The Matrix
when Neo and Trinity
set out on an impossible mission
to rescue Morpheus from the
clutches of the evil agents.
Our heroes are successful and for a second
it seems as though things
are starting to wrap up.
But that's not quite what happens here.
As they return to the
real world one by one,
they are compromised and Neo is left
to face the agents alone
for the first time.
- Neo.
- What the hell just happened?
- Narrator: This stage is
referred to as the road back
by Vogler where the hero
"begins to deal with the consequences
"of confronting the dark
forces of The Ordeal
"and is pursued by the vengeful
forces he has disturbed."
That's exactly what happens,
a chase between Neo and the agents
as he searches for a way back.
Neo is eventually cornered,
and then something truly unique happens.
(gun fires)
This scene came as a shock
to a lot of the people
watching The Matrix for the first time
and it's a shock that is well
deserved by the Wachowskis.
The film is riddled with uncertainties
about whether Thomas is truly Neo,
the prophesized chosen one.
At one point we even hear that he isn't,
from the prophet herself.
- You already know what
I'm going to tell you.
- I'm not the one.
- Sorry kid.
- Narrator: Ironically, and symbolically,
the person who has the
most trouble beleiveing
is none other than Thomas himself.
This is beautifully
visualized when Neo fails
to make a seemingly impossible jump,
a metaphorical leap of faith.
- You have to let it all go Neo.
Fear, doubt, and disbelief.
Free your mind.
- Narrator: And that's why perhaps
the best cinematic moment in The Matrix
happens in this scene.
- Mr. Anderson.
- Run Neo, run.
- Narrator: How do you visualize faith?
To the Wachowskis, that answer is choice.
Upon further viewing, it's surprising
to see just how many times choices
are visualized throughout the film.
But it asks the same question every time.
Do you choose to escape and avoid
the harsh reality of truth,
or do you choose to
confront and believe it.
When all odds are against Thomas,
he chooses to believe in himself.
- What is he doing?
- He's beginning to believe.
- Narrator: That's when we
witness a transformation,
a moment in which a
simple man becomes a hero.
And when our faith for the
hero is finally proven right,
it feels well deserved.
This stage, by the way, is
actually called resurrection,
where the hero is
"purified and transformed
"through the most dangerous
meeting with death."
And perhaps this is where a lot
of superhero films today fall short.
Most of them choose to
follow a safe, proven formula
that neither raises the stakes,
nor truly tests our hero.
- Anyone else?
- Narrator: We're supposed to
simply accept them as heroes
without knowing why it
is that they deserve it.
It makes for an easy viewing,
but also a highly predictable one.
There are of course a few exceptions,
most notably in films
like The Dark Knight,
or recently, Black Panther.
But it seems that many
still fail to understand
why it is that we love
superheroes so much.
As much as we love watching
our heroes fight and win,
it's the side of them
that makes them human,
their vulnerability, but
still the willingness to fight
against all odds, that
keeps us coming back.
Because it's only after
moments like these,
after a truly harrowing journey,
that a real hero is born.